everybody to Lauren Prime daily I'm
Jesse Weber still no arrests more than
three weeks after Ford University of
Idaho students were killed in a crime
that has rocked their small town
community and gripped the nation police
say they're still investigating
everything including the possibility
that one victim had a stalker thousands
of tips have been coming into the Moscow
police department and the FBI as they
look for both the suspect and the murder
weapon long crimes and Jeanette Levy is
in Moscow Idaho with the latest in the
investigation
crime scene tape still surrounds the
home here on King Road where those four
college students were murdered more than
three weeks ago a police officer is
always on duty guarding the house as the
investigation moves forward over the
weekend Kaylee Gonzalez's father said
her injuries were more brutal than the
other three victims which prompted
Moscow police to say on Monday they have
not released any information about the
victim's injuries to the public or the
victims families police have said all
four gonsalves Maddie Mogan Zana
kernodle and Ethan Chapin were stabbed
to death and some had defensive wounds
Steve gonsalves was also asked about
Kaylee's dog Murphy and whether he could
have had evidence on him police say
officers found the dog in a room where
the crimes were not committed but they
haven't determined where the dog was
located when the murders took place and
they did not find any evidence on him
police have previously said victims
Ethan Chapin and xana kernodle returned
to the King Road house around 1 45 a.m
on November 13th and were believed to be
at a party at the sigma Kai house
earlier that evening detectives are
working to learn more about their
whereabouts between 9 pm and 1 45 am in
an update on its Facebook page Moscow
police say they understand there's a lot
of frustration because they haven't
released a lot of information about the
case but they say they are not willing
to do that because it could compromise
the investigation and a possible future
prosecution in Moscow Idaho I'm
Anjanette Levy for Law and crime daily
all right I'm joined by my co-host Brian
buckmeyer and Terry Austin Brian I'm
going to start with you how do you think
the police could create a timeline for
Chapin kernodles whereabouts and how do
you think that's going to help the
investigation yeah so Jesse I've seen it
often in cases that I cover myself what
they do is they're going to start with
probably uh where their cell phones were
where their opinion they know where they
started from this frat party they know
where they ended and that being their
home and so they're going to use their
geo location they're going to use any
social media maybe people were tagging
them in photos maybe they were attacking
other people in photos they're also
going to kind of go through the
community and see if there are any small
businesses or Banks or places that may
have cameras on the outside so they can
watch their path back to the home and
with that they can see hey we're someone
stalking them with someone watching them
does someone follow maybe an hour or two
afterwards and make it to the home after
that that timeline is going to help
those investigation and connect some of
these pieces Terry my understanding is
the authorities are still waiting for
DNA results which we know is always
important how do you think that's going
to assist them in finding the suspect oh
it's critical vehicle to have that DNA
and unfortunately does take some time to
get back there's going to be or should
be DNA from blood samples because when
you're in a knife battle and and if
there were defensive wounds there
probably was some sort of struggle
chances are you did get cut and there
should be blood from the assailant in
that building also there should be some
touch DNA the person had to get or there
might have been a number of people into
the rooms of the victims and they
probably touched things as they went
into that room obviously they could have
worn gloves but what the authorities are
hoping is that there is DNA that they
can attach to whoever that assailant is
all right well hopefully the
investigators know a lot more about who
may have done this than we know right
now and we're going to continue to
follow it here on Long crime daily
Connecticut police say a 31 year old man
killed and dismembered his daughter and
then went on the Run police caught off
with him in Naugatuck Connecticut and
rushed him telling him to get the ground
the police chief says someone recognized
Christopher Francis queeney and called
9-1-1 authorities say Francis queeney
choked stab and misdismembered 11th
month old Camilla in their home last
month according to police the suspect
also got into an argument with Camilla's
mother destroyed her cell phone and
removed a GPS tracking device from his
ankle now he's had multiple run-ins with
law enforcement and was convicted of
first degree assault in 2013. now over
to Colorado Springs where the gunman
responsible for the Club Q mass shooting
is officially charged with a whopping
305 counts the shooter's charges include
first-degree murder attempted
first-degree murder assault and hate
crimes charges this all coming according
to Tuesday's filing now this is all in
connection to the November attack that
took the lives of five people at an
lgbtq nightclub 17 others were injured
as well in 2021 the gunman was arrested
on felony menacing and kidnapping
charges after a woman claimed she was
being threatened with a homemade bomb
multiple weapons in ammunition now the
gunman wasn't formally charged in that
situation but a court hearing is
scheduled for Thursday to discuss
whether details in that case should be
unsealed